in that first year I know you said
there's plenty of obviously you being
naive what have you got to lose but what
was I guess most challenging that first
year that you least expected
I think it was like personal battles I
think there's a bit of an ego that
probably came with it because it started
doing well so I think the clients in our
three four that I was the man to a
certain degree but age came into it a
lot right a lot of we gave me clients
and stuff like that and they'd look at
me and they'd be like you're a kid I
wear that so much and I was there like
yeah but okay let's say if you go and
dealt with a consultant out one of the
bigger agencies the likely is they're
going to be severaged to me right so we
had that quite a lot and that was
something that was used against us and
now we switched it around now we use it
in a more positive way managing people
that are older than me that was a real
big challenge just more the learning
curve for me I probably did it wrong as
well like looking back there's probably
certain things I should have done a bit
better but I'd say they were the big big
challenges in that first year so quite a
lot of anchored to your age then it
always is always was at a start the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincere and the
award-winning Source breaker
[Music]